muslims in norway are now establishing a
masjid and dawa center to enhance the
norwegian dawah if you donate to this
course you will ensure allah reap the
rewards of thousands of muslims coming
back to islam and many of those who
become dwight and invite to islam so
click the link and donate now and share
the video for extra rewards
i'm joined with the legend the man the
legend the steel man the historical
figure
[Laughter]
for us many of you would have known this
is the trainer
head trainer head coach in tri-state gym
it seems one of the best if not the best
you could argue uh trainer in the world
in mma now
this video is about how
to defeat a bigger opponent now i'm
noticeably sizable compared to uh for us
but obviously not skillful you don't
need to go into that details
so with someone like me for us how would
you so say for example i'm covering that
can you grab that
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay so if i'm coming at you right
so i'm coming at you right now first
thing is i don't want to be on the same
line so your feet are pointing towards
me my feet are pointing towards you yeah
if we exchange your fist is likely to
land before mine because you've got a
longer reach yeah you got bigger weights
so one thing i like to do is like to
circle when you point your feet towards
me that's when i'm going to change back
direction as your feet lift the ground
to change direction okay that's what i'm
going to attack yourself so if i'm
constantly circling i'm sorry
certainly yeah so now look because
you're circling with me yeah i'm going
to go this way no i'm going to circle
this way now you're circling that way
i'm constantly
breaking the line i call it breaking
noise so if you put your fist like this
i want to be aimed for my face here i
want to be here and when you turn your
face your fist towards me i want to be
here enough i never want to be yeah face
to face with exactly and now i want to
create that i want to create that cut
back we call it a cutback so you go
right then to the left left then to the
right so we're talking about working in
circles here that's why i like to shadow
box oftentimes what i do is i put an
object on the floor like a boxing glove
yeah and i just teach my fighters to to
box around that glove
always circling always moving my head
because
his reach is longer yeah
but
but if i get here if i get here
the shorter man has an advantage now on
the outside you have the advantage yeah
on the inside if you watch this look if
you if you keep your shoulders up and i
put my shoulders down and we push each
other push push
look i'm stronger only because i'm lower
yeah my center of gravity is lower right
so when i get close to you you're going
to want to go down my height yeah now or
even if you push each other say we're
even okay now we're even so i want to
catch him tall yeah i'm circling i'm
circling and you if if you were trying
to chase me like this it's kind of very
tiring on the legs right yeah so you
have to relax your legs i want to catch
you tall i have a window of opportunity
when i come in here yeah now i'm going
to throw up then i got to get out again
because you're going to sit down with me
or you're going to grab me except right
so when you're fighting a taller
opponent one thing i really like to do
we're assuming this is not just a
striking affair right right right we're
gonna get to yeah wrestling soon yeah
but striking i can't stand in front of
you you have to circle okay because if i
stand here so you're either out or in
yeah
you've got a longer job than me if you
see if i try to punch you and you punch
me you're going to beat me every time
yeah so i got a circle i got a circle i
got to get you stepping i got to keep
the ranges off yeah i got to cut i got
to catch you want to cut back yeah okay
you know i got to catch you and come
back now when i fight a taller guy yeah
i like to shoot doubles but when i shoot
a double yeah i don't shoot and lift
because
their legs are so long that when you
lift they're still on the floor
unless they're heavy
so we're going to kosotogi so a trip so
watch out here i put my hook behind your
ankle like this
and now i don't have to lift you see i
would trip you down to the floor here's
what you call kasotogaki should i go
down
well yeah just be careful because all
right yeah so i want to trap their leg
as i shoot a double so i shoot
into a trap here i am like this
now i don't have to worry so much about
guillotine because even if you trap my
neck
because for you to make that guillotine
work you need your legs around my body
yeah i'm not going to let you put your
legs around my body see yeah because
that guilt is very weak
it lets you have your legs around my
body you have to put me inside the
garbage if you're getting into combat
god is it oh yeah if here if you have
any guilty no i could have a lot of
danger
yeah no i'm gonna want a baby here but
if i trip your leg yep
try to put me together okay now
try to choke me
because it's very difficult
because you don't have your legs wrapped
around my body yep see i'm gonna pump a
lot of your legs yeah so the two major
benefits is
when you shoot a double egg on a taller
guy you don't have to lift them if you
trip yeah
you give me those guys now all the tips
because you're so tall it's easier for
me to get to your ankle right but if you
were my height it would be lower because
your arms and shoulders would be easily
double for me then on my side
i'm trying to screw that's it
guys for taller guys i like when you're
the taller man i like body lock and trip
so if you body lock me because the thing
is my legs are too far if you go for my
legs it's too much too much of a
distance to get all the way down yeah
so i'm coming here yeah i really like it
like this yeah well now you could trip
my my my right leg with your left yeah
no no no you're with your left
hook
yeah you could you could put your foot
in the middle yeah and then kind of
throw me with your hip yeah like this go
up here i really like this for taller
guys
yeah so we're here like this body lock
yeah you put your leg inside and you
start to hit yeah
yeah yeah that's good for me no i mean
if you're coming to a double leg for me
yes how much around the front i like the
underhook so like can you shoot all my
legs
under hook see yeah this is one of many
ways okay and then you can get into your
body lock oh okay so if i shoot on you
you're gonna put your hands like this
all right
yeah you elevate me here there you go
now you can turn the tables on me
right exactly okay
what we call an ukigoshi hip one hip
because typically as kids they teach you
ogoshi which is two hips yeah but if i
do that you can grab my body and lift me
here yeah i'm too committed yeah so we
just go one hip like see i see one hip
and now we can ankle pick knee pig yeah
snap down etc
yeah so if i shoot on you
so if you're boxing yeah you got to be
quick to your other yeah exactly
there you go now i'm in trouble here now
you have a variety of takedowns one of
them being the hip toss
that's what we call ukigoshi what we've
seen you do as well
and this might be
we don't do a lot to be honest in the uk
because a lot of the
kind of gyms don't allow it they're more
traditional yeah which is heel hooks yes
and we've seen you do a lot of these
yeah yeah yeah you're you're known for
that i was in the heart club yeah it's
known for that so
with someone big like me
to what extent
would it make sense for you to go for a
hill hook
uh very like look look at the size of
our feet here put your foot here yeah
look he's got a much longer left lever
it's much easier for me to break your
leg than it is for you to break mine you
know what they say
good point
think about breaking a long branch or
breaking a small branch you can only
think the smaller branch have less
leverage so it's easier for me to grab
and break that so how would you go like
say for example i'm coming at you well
if we're standing i like to do something
called ashy slide okay so like i pretend
like i'm doing a double legs i'll do it
real slow okay yeah i'm shooting double
leg but then i slide underneath like
this oh nice and then what i do is i
like to push inside your thigh here like
this oh beautiful see now if you try to
punch me you won't be able to yeah no
chance you have no shot and i'll look
where your heel is yeah nowadays because
that thigh try to resist me it's
impossible yeah exactly you're just
you're just bringing yourself down to
the mat so that's the first thing i do i
can push inside the thigh now look at
that lever that we're talking about look
i'm breaking this ankle quite easily
it's beautiful yeah it's very very
difficult you try
here
you got nothing if i start cranking yeah
you won't be able to reach my body or
face
with that
do you feel like it's a good idea in the
mma setting because we've seen it not
work as well yeah of course of course of
course there's a there's a risk with
everything you know yeah i personally i
like to use that as a surprise once in a
while yeah i would prefer using the
double egg with the kosovo
yeah i want to be on top because you
can't hit me
when i'm on top you can but it's not
really effective yeah uh the other thing
i like to do is i like to duck under on
top guys like this
and get behind the wipes i'm in a
position of safety and would you go into
like a heel hook position from here
because from here from here i have a
variety of uh takedowns but the one i
like first is blocking the knee just
like this yeah and trying to get your
hands on the mat you see i'm blocking
your knee i'm putting my weight forward
and i'll have you in what we call a gut
wrench yeah from here i can climb to the
back
i can uh force you down to the mat
khabib business all the time of course
he's the master of gut wrench because
you can you can do
i might be wrong here but
you can drop down here
and you can you can but that's risky
that's risky because especially when
things are slippery when you do that i'm
just going to piss my legs up
you're on the floor i like those things
once in a while by surprise like if you
see that move that you did yeah shogun
tried it on jon jones in the title fight
oh yeah i thought it was a major mistake
because yeah he got to the waist of john
yeah he sat down and john just got to
lift his leg up because things are
slippery yeah yeah yeah and there's
punches involved why take the risk
you're behind the guy i'm in the safe
here
look i'm in such a safe position why
would i go here where you can now punch
me yeah boom like why would i put myself
in the line of fire when i'm behind you
and you can't hit me so i find it
strategically a mistake yeah it should
only be used in the most
dire circumstances you're losing you
need to break the guy's leg in the next
30 seconds or we lose okay take the same
thing with the foot looks and stuff yeah
exactly i'll use it because the thing is
technique
always has to be
uh
under strategy yeah i can't just oh i'll
do any technique no no no
we have a bunch of tools which tools do
we need to do this particular job
we have to scrutinize what tool you're
going to use don't just bring out the
chainsaw when we're trying to glue two
pieces together chainsaw's useless so
i think i try to put you on your back i
try to box you if i can't and i'm losing
then i'll do something more high risk
yeah
now
this is a good video uh this is uh
many people could be taking notes but
the guys on the outside the big guys
that's all guys are gonna feel this is
ridiculous they're gonna say now for us
telling all these smaller people how to
be the big guys but he hasn't said
anything about how the taller guys can
beat the smaller guys you don't need any
help look at me
but they say that yeah you know we
haven't had that much success in the ufc
um so what would you uh
say i like the job okay so like yeah i
think georgia had the longest switch in
this division that's why i really
designed this game to be a jabber so
number one rule about jabbing see look
look at my reach here yeah the second
i'm touch your hand to the wall the
second i punch at an angle towards the
ground
see i lost reach i'll go here here i
have maximum reach
here just punching downwards
is really really bad for me so if i'm
fighting a guy who's shorter than me and
i'm jabbing at an angle downwards i'm
actually not using my reach right i have
to get what we call eye level okay so
are you coming down yeah i'm coming down
to his level okay however that leaves me
more susceptible to kicks i have to be
aware of that i have a question here
yeah if you go down
for on the one hand yeah if he goes down
he's gonna have more reach well on the
other hand if you come and hit me now
are you not now
me being taller isn't that me forcing
you to extend your arm which requires
more reach well for the shorter guy i
want to close the distance then punch
common mistake this guy's punch on the
way in like great example mcgregor and
uh
jose jose aldo yeah
leaps in with a punch steps back home
catches him on the way in a taller guy
yeah you're the taller guy if i punch
from here you're gonna beat me because
your reach is longer yeah i gotta close
the distance like we talked about yeah
then i have to have the discipline to
withstand
to delay my strikes right now once i
close the distance now i actually have
more leverage than you yeah yeah yeah if
we punch each other from here i have
actually superiority a bunch of
uppercuts yeah uppercut is dangerous but
i still have more remember if we push
each other here push yeah who generates
more power yeah the guy who's shorter so
shorter guy has more leverage on the
inside taller guy has more leverage on
the outside correct yeah so to you to
maximize that job of yours you need to
get as short as me so what's going on
yeah if you look at georgetown pierre
versus matt sarah the rematch
george was short by sarah
okay he came in the first match where he
got knocked out he was tall and sarah
caught him with that oh
and dropped him and wobbled him and then
we corrected it's actually very good
yeah
yeah so calm down because you have the
you have the reach advantage i would use
the jab yeah exactly and i would be
using i'd be coming down you want to be
as short as me it's going to say level
you have to be at my level okay good so
now your job's in my way if i want to
get to you the job's in the way if
you're punching from up there yeah your
jab is actually not reaching me yeah
because it's actually it's much easier
for me to get get closer to you yeah
whereas if you get eye level i have to
do my my blitz or my closing this is
from further out so the the margin of
error is greater for me so i'm
constantly now i have that job between
between me and you you're keeping that
job between me and you at all times so
every time i try to sidestep and cut in
you're trying to pick me off with a job
okay so there's the same thing about
kicking range because kicking range is
different right when you squat down like
that yeah it's dangerous to do it
against a very strong kicker oh okay
sarah is not a strong kicker so it's a
perfect example when george fought beat
japan we did the same thing bjp mostly a
boxer not a kicker okay if you're
fighting a very very good kicker i
wouldn't recommend you getting that
short because you'll get your legs with
the body okay i see i see so watch i'll
just stay high and just uh you want to
find you want to find the balance i mean
i like to bring my legs up so i can
check immediately so i never put my
weight on the lead leg because then you
can you can kick it out from underneath
me see
so i'm always i'm always lifting my feet
when i walk okay you know i'm always
lifting my feet so if you kick my leg's
going to be out of the way
yeah exactly i'm always legs out of the
way see i'm never planted i don't like
to fight like that because i feel like i
can get
double leg kicked so that's the job what
else would you advise for people
um a good left hook
good left hook yeah told you bro yeah he
told me that's totally fantastic
i like your jab with your left hook the
left hook the way i like to throw it is
from here if i'm tall i put it here so
every time the guy comes forward yeah i
hooked like this from the head nice yeah
i don't do it doesn't even look it's not
telegraph something
if i'm much taller than my punch from
here yeah
it's a bit like what tyson fury does
right yeah exactly so now every time you
try to punch me i sweep
i sweep with my hook
it's not a it's not a short hook
it's a long slapping look even like if
you're looking
how are you doing are you chuckling
chocolate i used to do a reverse knuckle
okay because you used to because you
have more reach with a reverse knuckle
so here you see i lose a few inches here
i'm a little bit longer see
yeah well he's doing that yeah but if
you throw it from the hip yeah you could
really hurt me so get sideways a second
so if you punch from here with your jab
no no
boom that's it
and then if you see me reach the
distance you can throw your hook but
step step to the right sorry uh to my
right pivot no no with your with your
trail legs so the back leg here so watch
your you have your spot and one hand
again
oh okay
famous instance is uh mayweather
knockout ricky hatton like this yes
exactly you call it the checkbook so
every time i try to come inside try to
fight you keep your arm down here yeah
keep your shoulder pointed on my chin
that's it okay now when i come in here
you just throw that hook
now another important detail is your
head has to go over the trail knee right
here so you create a distance you're
using your reach
and you can see that my face is
underneath my shoulder so even if you
got passed you wouldn't catch up to me i
don't want my head up here i want my
head down here yeah see so that's two
things you've told me the jab yeah and
the the left hook the check
yeah um take downs you can even i mean
it's not wrong to shoot doubles it's
just further away so you have to be for
me so for a taller person you're saying
number one is body blocks and number two
is what singles because it's quite i
mean um my arms are quite long so if if
the person comes a bit
i like i like
i like singles i like underhooks i like
body locks i like it all yeah for a tall
guy i really like underhook yeah so when
i'm on the hook like this yeah i want to
keep our feet perpendicular i want to
try to avoid it's not always possible
but being chest to chest like this you
know okay so i want to be here like this
now from here i'm going to lift this
and i'm going to trap your far knee so i
have a diagonal control i have control
over your left side now i have control
over your right side
so now i have a diagonal control if i
run you over here you're going to fall
it's called a knee tap this is one very
important technique yeah so when i do
that if you would draw your leg if you
would drive i'd pull you in for a
headlock yeah so you're kind of caught
in a dilemma so if you under hook me
here you have control of my right side
now you want to control my left side so
you would control my left knee here yeah
and throw my right side over my left
right side over the left throw my
shoulder yeah exactly so you would be
exactly exactly there so you're bringing
me down to the oh god it's called anita
that's him over so here so here in here
yeah exactly yep now if i resist that
yeah
my feeble knee tap try to grab the back
of my knee pull on it pull it yeah if i
resist it by going here boom you pull me
in for a headlock so you have the guy in
a type of dilemma yeah
now you can make it a trilemma okay by
going here yep snap down or here like
what we did earlier yep so i have this
triple attack that's brilliant and so
i'm here before the guy takes this away
back up
he takes the head away yeah
boom okay i have a triple attack yeah
that i can change yeah now you've got
the car wrenches
yeah yeah so the nice sequence of
attacks it's beautiful
yeah it doesn't make sense for big guys
to go down and do like heel hooks
nothing though no no it does it does
there's a time and place for that but uh
i feel like if our legs are so different
in size it's very hard for each one of
us to like like one another yeah there's
a weakness to every submission yes if i
see your legs are that long yeah
i feel you can't really legalize me it's
gonna be hard not impossible very hard
because my feet are smaller my legs are
shorter but i can like lock you so yeah
leg lock wars i have the advantage
triangle chokes you're much more
superior than me because you have longer
legs yeah arm triangle i don't want to
be i don't know
but even let's say i shoot on you i
really worry because whenever i see a
guy with long arms the anaconda choke
the dark strokes are usually very
dangerous yeah
not as much guillotine guillotines more
shorter guys shorter arms yeah yeah yeah
so you have we each have advantages and
disadvantages now armbar i can break
your arm much more easily yeah sure then
you can break mines your arm is longer
yeah so in an armbar i actually have an
advantage armbar escape so
if i had the choice to give you triangle
or armor i'll offer you armbar wow
because you have less chance to finish
my arm yeah yeah
it's harder to triangle one last thing i
wanted to ask you because you know i
know your time's gonna take but you know
in terms of the heel hook escape
how am i getting out of that because you
told me how to do it or that you would
do it but then how am i getting can you
lay down it's actually pretty
let's do a 50 50 level okay it's
actually pretty dangerous
okay it's actually so if you he'll hook
me now can you hear me it's actually
great
if i hold you here like this try to
break my leg here go ahead try to break
now this yeah try to make a chair
i'm holding on your arms it's actually
really difficult
if if i'm if i'm close enough to hold
your hands yeah
how would you break my leg now go ahead
here i'll try to get rid of this right
let's give you that
scrambled against your heel up go ahead
yeah try to heal with me i can't do it
now try
okay look let's see how look yeah go go
ahead go ahead go ahead
look i'm holding your arms go ahead
it makes it very vulnerable
try it's right it's actually very
difficult yeah if i'm holding your arms
see i'm hiding my feet so
do it
yeah that's not easy at all come on
i like to hold the hands like
gary toner versus tom lee yeah that's
what he's holding the hand okay and he
pushed down from there
you twist away i'm gonna hide my feet
and then separate your legs now i'm
gonna start separating your legs once
your legs are separated try to reconnect
your legs together it's not easy
okay my knee yeah yeah so what i do is
i try to intercept the hands yeah
i try to get out two on one
two hands as many hands i can grab yeah
i get up on my foot yeah when my hips
are off the floor it's harder not
impossible yeah
but much harder for your leg up with me
that's good from there i try to separate
the feet yeah once i separate the feet i
try to scrape my knee beautiful this is
one way to go about it that's fantastic
man
that's how you do it okay
if you if you even took
like
10 of that 20 30
that might save your life one day
but most important can you hear me in
that book which one
some people never learned
some people will never learn
wow that's what he does explains the
good nature of people
now you know i'm in his head you see
i mean
all right guys it's like a naive child
to me you see how can we how can we get
your stuff where is it on uh check out
jujiclub.com yeah and you've got your
youtube channel is
uh tristar gym check out tristar gym i
do a lot of uh tutorials and stuff like
that fantastic guys make sure you
subscribe to this channel and mine as
well so i want to come after live
muslims in norway are now establishing a
masjid and our center to enhance the
norwegian dawah if you donate to this
course you will ensure allah reap the
rewards of thousands of muslims coming
back to islam and many of those who
become dwight and invite to islam so
click the link and donate now and share
the video for extra rewards